I am Parker Conrad I'm founder of
zenefits I'm here to talk about about
growth Parker Conrad is the luckiest guy
on the planet right now this company is
growing faster than any other company
Parker Conrad is a master of raising the
stakes $4.5 billion do valuations how
can zenefits possibly be worth 4 billion
after just 2 years zenitz was the
fastest growing company in Silicon
Valley history the investors are
investing on the promise of a lot of
future growth Parker was at the top of
the world but he never could predicted
what happened next Zenit is now being
investigated by California and
Washington State it's no secret that
like at my last company like we we made
some mistakes there's a lot about the
public story about inits that I just vly
disagree with Parker was forced to leave
his own company I agreed to step down
under a lot of pressure so he decided to
start from scratch and build a direct
competitor to zenefits Rippling really
has one underlying Insight we run hard
and push the limits of possible I wanted
to to know how he's navigated every
crisis he's faced so I sat down with him
and his team to understand what it takes
to build the same company
twice okay so before we start the video
some quick background on How I Met
Parker we both went through white
combinator around the same time and he
actually emailed me to try and get me to
use zenitz back in around 2013 I wound
up using the software and really liked
it and we had a bunch of mutual
connections but we never really met then
earlier this year I became a
entrepreneur and Residence at Founders
fund and we met met at a CEO Summit like
an offsite and uh started talking and I
realized that there was a really
interesting story here that I thought
would be valuable to tell on the channel
now full disclaimer ripling doesn't see
this video they're not paying me for
this video no one suggested this video
to me all these opinions are my own I
just think it's a fantastic story and
it's one of the greatest comeback
stories in Silicon Valley history so I
hope you really enjoy
it
before Parker cracked the code on
building high- growth enterprise
software companies his journey began
with a passion for science in high
school he won a $20,000 scholarship in
the prestigious Westinghouse science
Talent search for his research on sea
snails this propelled him into Harvard
where he worked at the Harvard Crimson
the same newspaper where JFK FDR and
Tech leaders like Andy jassi all worked
but his maniacal focus on the paper
ended up distracting him from school and
he had to take a leave of absence he it
back though graduated and got a job at a
pharmaceutical company he had a very
stable life at this point but he wanted
more you know I kind of looked at the
sort of career path at that company and
there were all these rules about you
know spending a certain number of years
in this role and then in this role and
and then you know sort of you could move
up only with it you know you know once
every two or 3 years or something like
that and if you add up like all the
steps I was like geez I'm going to be
dead before I get to the top here that
was sort of the real impetus for me to
you know to leave and and one of my
roommates from college wanted to start a
company and I thought man if if this
thing works Mike does it and I don't I'm
going to be an old man like kicking
myself that's how Parker and his
roommates started wicking vest later
renamed SigFig the company functioned as
a robo adviser enabling consumers to
make investment decisions however having
two CEOs at SigFig led to operational
challenges resulting in a split between
Parker and his co-founder it was time
for something new so in sep M of 2012
Parker founded his new Venture
zenitz the idea from zenitz for zenitz
was really I had had this problem
managing health insurance for SigFig you
know anytime we needed to hire a new
employee you know they had to fill out
their their paperwork to enroll in
health insurance and I needed to like
stop off at Kinko's to like fax in the
application because that was the only
way to kind of get it in the insurance
company at that point and you know I
thought like gez this makes no sense
like this has got to move online and so
on Monday we announced the launch of our
HR as a service platform and this is
important we do all of it for free
because we make money on the insurance
commissions it turns out that you know
when we had that type of business where
there was sort of all of this money
flowing in those were exactly the kinds
of businesses that VC's wanted to invest
in and and we were able to raise
enormous amounts of capital Zenit is
shaking up the human resources software
business it just got a cash infusion of
half a billion
that now values this 2-year-old company
at $4.5 billion why do you need that
kind of money we feel that you know what
the market that we're going after is
absolutely enormous it solves a really
big problem for almost any business in
the United States and we think it that
you know if if we don't screw it up in a
couple years a lot of the guys in this
round will look precient the trend of
satification is accelerating and what
that means is the best SAS companies are
growing faster than ever how did you
land David acts as your coo says I felt
like it was sort of handed to me on a
silver platter zenitz looked like the
perfect company but then everything
started falling
apart the relationship between
regulators and silicon Valley's drive
for disruption is being tested zenitz is
being investigated in at least two
states over allegations employees sold
insurance policies without proper
licensing BuzzFeed writes this article
saying benefits has these aspiring
insurance brokers who are not licensed
in all the states that they should be
the story is that there was this thing
that the company's calling the macro
which is basically a software tool that
says okay I'm taking training the
training's 52 hours long the macro sort
of deceives the the licensing tool into
thinking that I'm paying attention all
52 hours when I might not be definitely
there was a big push to sort of Parker
you need to step aside this is a big
deal David saxs has not minced words in
uh announcing this transition saying for
us compliance Is Like Oxygen without it
we
die as Co of the company I own those
mistakes but there's a very different
sort of moral character I think to like
hey we made a mistake and we screwed
this up because we we didn't realize
what was required and like setting out
to sort of like subvert like the
regulatory regime which was like never
the intention I was never to say that
and then sort of watched this whole
thing unfold around me with this sort of
growing horror of sort of realizing sort
of what was being told about this I
agreed to step down under a lot of
pressure and there was this sort of
agreement that we were all going to kind
of March forward arm in- arm over this
transition and we drafted this press
release that was a friendly press
release and uh David just issued a
different press release and I talk about
this mostly to
emphasize just the level of of like
horror that I saw like when this stuff
did in fact come out because it was not
what I was expecting when I when I
resigned there's this the sort of media
view of like Founders you're either a
superhero or a super villain and there's
such a like thin fuzzy Gray Line between
those two and you can slip so easily
from one to the other I've been
portrayed as both in in the media at
various different points and I think
that um that that um that's the thing I
wish I could change when I was forced
out of the company there was this board
meeting and at the board meeting Andre
and Horowitz L Lars and Ben tried to
convince me to stay on and so I said
look if I'm out I'm out I remember like
in in that board meeting um you know
they said well what are you going to
do I worked with Parker and like he had
like very clear idea maze on the
territory he knew every turn that you
could take in the space and what would
what would be the result of those
turns once the company lost him and it
was sort of trying to not innovate and
trying to just like optimize on its cash
flows and stuff I knew like the next day
it was over and I and I quit and I also
knew that no one else is going to do
this it was this sort of giant 100
billion Market yeah that was waiting to
be
[Music]
taken I actually wrote to Parker saying
uh dude I know you're going to start a
company I would love to join you and
Parker was like you know I'm actually
going to Europe I'm going to you know
take a big vacation in Europe I don't
know if I'll come back you know I wrote
back to him saying I know you're going
to start a company I would love to join
you and then in the press the investors
and everyone was was just blaming all
the failures on him he was under an NDA
so he couldn't talk back to the press
and they you know the investors could
talk all they want and he couldn't say
his side of the story he was severely
depressed I did read the zenefits
articles unlike Parker press described
Parker as this like very unethical
person that's just an example of like
how off the person that was being
written about or or portrayed compared
to like the actual person that I knew
and know quite well I really felt for
him um it wasn't
[Music]
fair so whereabouts we heading today to
interview Parker
Conrad the man who built the same
billion dollar company
twice
[Music]
I thought that by leaving I was like
saving the
company David he probably had a lot of
answers like maybe he was going to turn
everything around and fix it and then it
just became so clear um that like you
know he was canceling all the wrong
projects and firing all the wrong people
and like David announced like this
really big layoff and I was like this is
crazy the company's not going to be able
to survive or it's not going to sort of
move forward and do the things that it
needs to do and that was when you know I
called up person I was like okay like
yeah let's do it Parker needed to prove
that he was the real deal so he teamed
up with person to launch ripling a
direct competitor to zenefits there were
still a few investors who had their
backs and wrote checks to help get
Rippling started Gary tan the CEO of
white combinator was doubling down on
Parker and Matt mcginness his old
college friend was steadfast in his
support Parker and I went to Maxwell's
coffee on 16th Street in San Francisco
and sat down at a table and he took out
a piece of paper under the Affordable
Care Act and starts drawing out the idea
for like plan
selectors and did the same crazy thing
again not like go chill out on the beach
for 9 months and regain your you know
composition but like composure rather
but like go do it again and I did I did
think it was
unhealthy I think that he sort of
channeled depression anger like like
lots of emotion like negative emotion
into I'm going to build the biggest
company I possibly
can some of the biggest stories in the
world have played out on our TV sets but
which moments have been the most
memorable for the first time the 45th
president of the United States of
America Donald J Trump Jeff Bezos became
the world's richest man on Thursday will
you return as James Bond yes Mark
Zuckerberg to At Last earn his Harvard
degree for Best Picture La La Land
there's a mistake Moonlight you guys won
best
picture this time around Parker had a
significant Advantage his experience at
zenitz gave him a clear view of the
inefficiencies within the HR business
really the fundamental problem was that
almost every business system that
companies use is full of information
about employees and that information
needs to be maintained and updated you
know companies would build these sort of
big checklists of things they need to do
every time they hire someone and and I
thought man we should just like you know
here's the list and like zenefits is
kind of only going after this portion of
it and in fact they're kind of
retrenching and it's getting smaller and
no one's trying to take on the whole
thing when I went to Parker's house and
he pulled out his laptop and he started
join me like this is what I want to
build he had remodeled his basement to
fit 10 to 15 of the first
employees Parker was like ready to
zenefits 2.0 it and I was not like the
Articles were still coming
out why do you go back to YC starting a
company it's sort of it superficially
feels like being unemployed and I think
that YC is really good at like the first
time I did it it was the three most
productive months of my life and it's
weirdly good it just sort of really gets
you into this incredible pace of
execution the product Parker had
envisioned was starting to take shape
the goal was we wanted to launch with a
core feature set that included payroll
you know a lightweight HRS system device
management software and single sign on
and um identity Parker had found a
unique wedge to get companies to start
using ripling and once they were on
boarded ripling could make way more
money off a single Customer because they
bundled so many solutions together see
Parker had realized that in order to
really succeed in this industry you had
to build what he calls a compound
startup the conventional wisdom on how
you should build a company is that you
want to like Focus really narrowly and
build one extremely narrow thing and go
very deep on it and I think that a lot
of that that conventional wisdom is
wrong and I think that at least for rip
Lan we've sort of taken the opposite
tack um and it's it's something we've
talked about before that I call a
compound startup which is basically
doing a bunch of different things in
parallel and there are some inherent uh
product advantages and some inherent
sales and marketing advantages that you
have over a lot of like Standalone
systems was by definition compound
startups are solving like different
problems than Co solution products it's
why the company has really unusual
growth persistence um you know like
highly anomalous in terms of how much
our growth rates have persisted
year-over-year
everything was going exactly to plan but
then the team faced their first big
[Music]
crisis one Friday shortly after I joined
it was less than a year into my job here
we start getting these support tickets
rolling in that some people had not been
paid which of course is a red alert
immediately you're like okay there might
be something wrong
here as a payroll company we move money
for customers so they you know we debit
their accounts and then we send money
along to employees and to government
agencies we had a company that onboarded
that had a a very weird character in the
company name that character caused a
problem and the process crashed Parker
and I divided and started dialing the
CEOs of these companies to say hey your
employees are not going to get paid
today but like I remember one company in
particular was a trucking company and
they ran a fleet of vehicles in
California and Nevada and when I told
the CEO that a bunch of his employees
were not going to get paid there was
this deafening silence on the other end
of the
line and then he said like he there's a
few guys in my team were probably going
to miss their mortgage and they might
lose their
homes but it was Friday and so you can't
move money easily in the banking system
in this country on Saturdays and Sundays
and so they weren't going to get paid
till Monday and so what are we going to
do we called the banks we called was
like how can we move money how do we do
this the only service the bottom feeding
money movement service of America is is
Western
Union we pulled out our credit cards and
we all Parker and I and other set of
team members went to ATMs and pulled out
as much cash it was like 9:00 p.m. on a
Friday night as much cash as we possibly
could to like make it right for these
customers and went to the Western Union
Terminal and started trying to pump this
money
through everyone was actively
involved like that is something that was
like really critical at the
moment that night was
rough the most important aspect of that
experience from my perspective and it
imprinted upon me like the gravity of
what we do
here for me it's a story about really
serving our customers and really kind of
getting to ground on
things the great leaders here right they
don't just like hover like above like
the unwatched masses like you do this
you do this you do that so you go all
the way to ground and you figure out oh
my gosh this is a problem I'm going to
help solve it directly right I'm
accountable for this thing that's going
on very deep in my arur this thing
that's going on for the company and like
it doesn't really matter what it is that
it takes to solve this I'm going to go
do
that with the lessons learned from the
Western Union fire drill ripling kept
scaling Parker had built highly
collaborative culture in the Rippling
office where sales people would often
work right alongside Engineers to make
sure the product was working as intended
rling has this idea of go and
see which means that even if you are a
sea level executive like you will find
your way down to the deepest basement or
the you know the furthest corner of a
problem from time to
time I think Parker has an enormous
amount of insight about what matters
right now like he's very good at
synthesizing across like all the
feedback he's getting kind of internally
from customers from like the market and
saying H here's this thing that matters
right now and he's the primary user of
the entire product right and so he can
speak with an enormous degree of depth
about
things and what Parker does is he is
still the first five employees and the
thing is all day every day constantly
relentless ly pushing the system back to
the to the place it's supposed to be
which is a really important
characteristic of a of a good
leader and at the very moment when the
Rippling team had mastered their
workflow functioning like a finely tuned
machine the most unexpected event
unfolded covid-19 can be characterized
as a
[Music]
pandemic all over the world we're seeing
the devastating impact of this Invisible
Killer Corona virus officially hitting
the US here's what we know the breaking
news stay at home that is the order
tonight from four state
[Music]
Governors covid had dramatically
increased the pace at which companies
were hiring employees internationally
every company had to make adjustments
during the pandemic but ripling was
forced to confront a new challenge
International
competition the the idea of needing to
manage a Workforce
globally was previously something that
was like you know that only happened for
companies that were thousands of people
like no no mid-market companies would
ever do
that now everyone was hiring remotely
and like ripling was really really well
positioned to support people who needed
to like do things electronically and
like get laptops to their employees
through mail and those sorts of
systems and so it's clear that there was
like a real need for this and it was one
of these things that was enough of a
crack in the system for businesses that
either we could do it and Rippling could
become really huge by solving that
problem or someone else was going to do
it and it was going to become a point of
exposure for
us I didn't really think that that was
possible I thought it was just going to
be too hard and there was internally an
engineer that sort of said no I think I
want to do this and take it on but as a
result of that
we launched this product and the product
went
from0 to 12 million in ARR in 4
months the plan worked Rippling had
stemmed the bleeding and covid led to a
huge boost in business it looked almost
certain that Parker would succeed in
surpassing zenefits even though the
pandemic wound up being a positive
opportunity for Rippling it led to new
challenges that would put everything to
the test the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank the biggest bank collaps since the
2008 financial crisis it is the 16th
largest bank or it was in the United
States and this is really the epicenter
of tech startups Venture Capital the
management of these banks will be fired
investors in the banks will not be
protected when Banks experience
Financial losses it is and should be a
matter of concern customers of Silicon
Valley Bank lined up to make sure that
they can get their money it's not clear
if they're going to get all of their
money back
Co lockdown spiked unemployment which
led to government stimulus which led to
inflation which led to Rising interest
rates and this was a big problem for
svb svb is just an example of interest
rate
risk and so for SCB they had all their
money in bonds and treasuries because
they like oh this is safe and when the
FED raises raised that really reduced
the value of the bonds that SV was
holding and made newer bonds much more
valuable and so if you have deposit over
250,000 like above 250,000 you're not
insured by the FDIC anymore and so
because SBB Silicon Valley Bank was
insuring or had the deposits of all
these you know tech companies all these
VCS they were exposed not only to the
tech recession and so they were
struggling with deposits they were
struggling with the treasuries that they
had the Fed was raising rates so fast so
Furious you just saw people try and take
money out of svb and that created this
whole abomino
effect we were using svb for day one and
we were using them for a very specific
reason which was that ripling moves
money on behalf of our clients for that
you need to have money transmission
licensing you know you don't have money
transmission licenses as a startup and
so svb has this thing where you can
effectively they structure these
accounts in this way where the account
that money is moving through is not our
account it's Silicon Valley Bank
account when did you first hear
Rumblings that things might not be okay
at svb there's a former colleague of
mine he called me up and was like Hey
like what are you doing about svb and I
was like what are you talking about
right after that call I I had my
one-on-one with
Albert and so I remember sitting in the
meeting room and you Barker walks
in I forget exactly what he said but
something like hey this is starting to
look really serious and and so
immediately you know it came down to who
did we need to get in the room across
the team to start working on this and it
felt a bit like The Avengers assembling
cuz literally from every corner of the
building people almost like came running
to this like corner office where we were
meeting we called an emergency board
meeting so that we could tell our board
like hey I think we're going to trigger
wires to move you know $500 million over
to JP
Morgan and this was on Thursday but we
still thought that this would be weeks
away and then I got a phone call at 5:00
a.m. Friday morning that payments hadn't
gone out I got a call from my CMO who's
like you need to wake up there's all
these people complaining that they
didn't get paid and I was like oh
crap you know we had I think about 130
million that we needed for Friday and it
exceeded the sort of capital that we had
available ourselves you know outside of
what was already stuck in svb I went out
and started made phone calls to a bunch
of investors to try and raise additional
Capital it was a record fundraising I
started talking to folks 9:00 a.m.
Friday morning and we signed a term
sheet at 9:00 p.m. to raise $500 million
the same day the same day what are you
going to do with that 500 million yeah
so we raised the money to make sure that
we'd be able even if the the FDIC did
nothing that we'd be able to back stop
our client funds we wanted to make sure
that any company that had sent us money
we were going to get their employees
paid raising $500 million in less than
24 hours isn't easy but getting the
funds they needed was only half the
battle the team had to quickly figure
out how to get money flowing through the
payroll system
again we sort of moved Heaven and Earth
to get a payments file over and
generated for jpmc to pay people on
Friday there was like one or two key
Engineers like running the the right set
of you know of scripts to like prepare
the file and upload it um and so we're
we're all literally like watching them
and like you're watching the time tick
by and you know they're like okay it's
uploaded okay uh you know the banks
received it but it's 6 minutes late and
we're like no and they're like but it
looks like it's starting to go through
you know the money's flowing and so it
was this like crazy emotional roller
coaster of like 30 people watching you
know like two Engineers like move this
one key
file the amount of money the billions of
dollars that were flowing into and out
of accounts across two Banks and the
soft our software being like what is
happening because the software yeah
contemplated a certain configuration and
all of a sudden we were at JP Morgan you
know and svb wasn't under the hood of
the system anymore and so you know Apple
shifted from you know the power PC
architecture to the Intel architecture
over two years that was a hard you know
it's like I know that's an over rod
analogy but like for us we were
switching underlying architectures over
10 days
yeah the plan worked not only did Parker
raise half a billion dollars but ripling
was also able to switch banking Partners
without delaying
paychecks I have not worked that hard
for 10 consecutive days in my life and
that is saying a lot cuz I have worked
freaking hard in my career but to hop
out of bed at 6:00 a.m. on Saturday to
hop out of bed at 6:00 a.m. on Sunday to
get straight in front of my computer and
just keep hacking at this with the team
to make sure we were getting it right
was like it was in high it was
exhilarating and and purposeful uh but
man it was
intense how would you characterize like
how the company had changed by the end
of the the weekend culturally it was a
good reminder of what we can do it made
very very clear like a set of people who
were very deep and committed and
talented contributors to the company who
like may have been like working away in
the boiler room for a while but like in
this context were're able to like stand
up and like do something really
important when Parker spoke to the media
about the svb incident they no longer
introduced him as the former CEO of
zenefits but simply as the current CEO
of Rippling CEO of payroll service
provider Rippling Parker Conrad it was a
moment of real transformation Parker
getting recognized for what he really
was an experienced business leader with
a steady hand on the wheel during a time
of
Crisis it it's no secret that like at my
last company like we we made some
mistakes despite what the media
narrative was about this they were they
were like unintentional and we we
thought the rules were one thing it
turned out they were another so we've
been extremely careful about
that when people ask me what Parker is
like I like to describe him as he's he's
sensitive but not terribly empathetic he
cares what people think about him and if
he does something wrong wants to make it
right but when I say he's not
particularly empathetic I just mean it's
not his first reaction to worry about
how you're going to feel when he tells
you something that's inconvenient for
you to hear I think that combination of
sensitivity and slightly lower empathy
is what unlocks his potential as a
leader even with the SBB crisis in the
rearview mirror the story of Rippling
isn't over the Journey of Parker Conrad
and ripling is one of the greatest
comeback stories in the history of
Silicon Valley fundamentally Parker knew
something everyone else didn't and just
refused to quit until it was a reality
it's an amazing story so hopefully you
learned something valuable from this and
thanks for
[Music]
watching